while the UAE doesn't consume as much
water as United States or New Zealand
they do consume 550 liters of water per
person per day which is well above the
international average of 170 to 300
liters per day as the UAE rapidly
expands its need for water is
exponentially growing as well Abu
Dhabi's annual water demand itself is
expected to grow by as much as 123
percent by 2030 and as the UAE located
in the middle of a desert natural rain
water is simply not going to do it in
fact the UAE averages just under 100
millimetres of rainfall per year
currently their solution for this water
demand is desalination as 98.8% of
Dubai's pond water comes from
desalination only 1.2 percent of their
water comes from underground and that's
their only other major source as a
result as the UAE has been looking into
alternatives they came up with making
artificial clouds using cloud seeding to
understand how exactly this works we
have to first understand how clouds are
formed clouds are essentially tiny water
droplets or ice crystals that form when
water vapor in the atmosphere cools and
condenses around a particle of dust or
salt consequently a particle of dust or
salt is required for clouds to form and
a lack of these result in a lack of
clouds cloud seeding attempts to solve
this issue by releasing various salts
like silver iodide into the atmosphere
either through a plane or a ground-based
device they target up crafts a Veyron or
increased a likelihood of water vapor
molecules clouding with the salt
particles and forming clouds this is
actually not a new method by any means
and has been around for almost a century
it all started in 1946 when a chemist
named Vincent Schaffer working at
General Electric got snow to fall by
dropping dry eyes into a cloud since
then this technique has been used
throughout history for various uses in
the 1950s France actually tried using
cloud seeding to produce hail their
experiments showed that cloud seeding
influences more smaller hail particles
to form rather than less larger hail
particles in the late 1960s and early
1970s the u.s.
try using cloud seeding in Vietnam and
Laos in an effort to boost the length of
the monsoon season at the time this was
actually a top-secret project called
Operation Popeye the UAE picked up on
the strategy in the early 1990s but it
was until a couple of years ago that
they seriously started cloud seeding
since 2015 the UAE government has funded
15 million dollars for nine cloud
seeding projects some of these have been
directly involved in process of cloud
seeding while others are more concerned
about further research to improve the
method this is all cool and stuff but
how effective actually is this process
well according to the NCM or National
Center of meteorology the UAE saw an
increase of forty six point five
millimeters of rainfall in 2018 after
184 clouding operations in 2019 this
number increased to 101.1 millimeters of
rainfall after 247 operations as of
January 19th 2020 the UAE has already
conducted 17 seeding operations this
year clearly they have not given up on
the process and believe that with
technological improvements they can
reach even higher numbers while these
numbers seem small consider that the UAE
naturally only gets less than 100
millimeters of rain per year these
increases are relatively impressive if
they were truly caused by cloud seeding
the NCM estimates that cloud seeding can
increase rainfall by 30 to 35 percent
but skeptics say that the increases in
rainfall in the UAE are simply due to
natural variation but even assuming that
cloud seeding is as effective as they
claim it's only useful if there was
already a decent amount of rainfall to
start with and the UAE also plans to
increase this as well by planting trees
trees not only reduce our carbon
footprint and create visual appeal in
scenery but can also increase rainfall
trees actually produce water as a
by-product during photosynthesis but of
course trees require water to grow as
well so scientists are not quite sure if
this produces or takes away water in the
long term however one way trees have
proven to help rainfall is
evapotranspiration when a does rain free
leaves catch
love this precipitation and this is
evaporated once again by reducing water
that is absorbed by the ground
Cree's are able to increase rainfall in
fact evapotranspiration accounts for 40%
of precipitation across the globe every
year on top of this Chris has proven to
be twice as effective as cropland and
bodies of water was a great way to
increase annual rainfall and a perfect
solution to the UAE s desert landscape
the Dubai Municipality planted 44,000
trees in Dubai in just 2018 adding 1.7
million square meters of greenery
furthermore the UAE s plan to plant 1
million trees across the UAE within the
next two years and we are already
starting to see positive effects the UAE
set a new rainfall record on January
12th 2020 when received 190 point 4
millimeters of rainfall over a period of
three days in all shockula Alpine of
course this definitely has to do with
the natural variation as well but it
seemed as if the extra trees and cloud
seeding have had a positive effect as
well finally if they're able to slowly
increase annual rainfall over a couple
of decades they can save a lot of money
on desalination plans to reduce marine
life damage due to altering salt
concentrations in the ocean an MCN s
meteorologist estimates at a cubic meter
water produced by desalination cost $60
while a cubic meter water produced by
claude seating only costs $1 on top of
this with a vapo transpiration and cloud
seeding they have the power of
compounding increases on their side a 30
percent increase in rainfall every
single year can quickly lead to the UAE
surpassing 500 millimeters or even 1,000
millimeters of rain per year which is
around what most developed countries
receive this will greatly reduce our
dependence on desalination plants and
make the UAE much more sustainable they
have already created artificial islands
in the world's tallest building so why
not make rain as well if you guys
thought this video explains cloud scene
well then mention drop a like and
consider subscribing if you like to see
more questions just like this one
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see
guys on the next one
[Music]